One way to change how many times a texture repeats is to modify the UV
coordinates of the square. This is a bit intrusive, you have to modify the
geometric mesh itself. 3JS has an alternate solution. It allows you to set two
parameters on the texture called repeat and offset. These define a transform
for the texture coordinates themselves. Repeat is essentially a scaling
operation saying how many times a texture should repeat across the surface.
Offset is a translation adding to the uv coordinate after scaling. Varying the
offset shifts the texture. One use of this parameter is that you can animate a
texture. For example, if you have a river, you can make the water flow by
slowly changing one texture coordinate over time. Here you can see the effect
of changing the repetition. If you repeat a texture too much, it becomes fairly
obvious that it's being repeated. There are advance solutions such as using
long tiles to break up this repetition. See the additional course materials for
more on this topic.